Today we're going to look at two cases,
mill's view,
Wyman and web,
the mcgalin to introduce the concept of moral obligation and the possibility of
moral consideration.
First,
let's look at the case of Mills v Wyman,
which was decided by the Supreme Judicial Court of Massachusetts in 1825 while
traveling abroad,
the Wymans adult son became ill and without Wyman's request or consent,
the plaintiff mills cared for Wyman son afterward,
Wyman promise to pay mills for his expenses,
but later recanted and refuse to pay.
Mills sued for enforcement of Wyman's promise.
The trial court granted defendant a nonsuit and the instant court affirmed.
So the issue is,
was the defendant's moral obligation arising from the plaintiff's care for the
sun,
sufficient consideration to bind his promise to pay?
And the answer is at least in 1825 no,
the court held that it was not according to the court,
a mere moral obligation,
a combined with a promise is not sufficient to enforce the promise even when
refusal to perform such a promise may be disgraceful.
The court acknowledged that moral obligation and a promise or sometimes
sufficient to qualify as consideration.
But only if there was a preexisting legal obligation at some time in the past.
For example,
if a debt was once owed,
but now has become unenforceable because the statute of limitations has run out,
uh,
to bring suit,
but the debtor then subsequently promises to repay the credit or any way the
debtors moral obligation of owing money in the past binds him because it stems
from this preexisting legal obligation combined with the subsequent promise
absence of preexisting legal obligation oil.
However,
the law leaves moral obligations to the conscience of the promissory note.
In the words of the court quote,
the law of society has left most of such obligations to the inferior forum as
the tribunal of conscience has been aptly called.
So remember,
timing is important.
Assume that Wyman learns that mills is caring for his adult son and promises
then to reimburse mills for his expenses.
If mills continues the care for his son.
And then mills continues to care for Wyman son,
but why I'm in later refuses to pay and mill Sue's Wyman for expenses incurred
after the promise was made.
Is there consideration?
Well,
of course in this alternative scenario,
Wyman promises to reimburse mills in exchange for continued care.
Wyman's promise comes before meals continued care not after,
as in the actual facts of the case mill's loses in this case because as a matter
of traditional contract law,
past consideration is no consideration.
Marxists can have a field day with this decision.
Past consideration is no consideration when you care for the sick,
ah,
la,
the Good Samaritan.
But it's sufficient when a capitalist lender might lose the right to collect on
a past debt.
Do now,
let's see how the court of Appeals in Alabama handled of similar promise 110
years later in the 1935 case of Web,
Cvi mcgalin web was an employee of McGowan's mill.
One day web was badly injured when he saved McGowan's life by diverting the path
of a 75 pound pine block that was falling from the upper stories of the mill
after the incident in return for saving his life,
uh,
McGowan promised to pay web $15 every two weeks or $390 per year for the rest of
webs life.
And these payments were made but after McGowan's death is executive refused to
continue making the payments.
Web sued for the,
for the continuation of the payments and the trial court found for the defendant
on the basis of the defendant's dimmer that there was no consideration but the
instant court reversed and remanded for a new trial and the issue in this case
was also is the defendant's moral obligation sufficient consideration to bind
him contractually?
Well,
in this case,
the court held it was the court articulates an exception to the past.
Consideration is no consideration rule and holds that a moral obligation is a
sufficient consideration to support a subsequent promise to pay where the
promise is received a material benefit,
although there was no original duty or a liability resting on the promise or in
other words,
material benefit plus moral consideration plus subsequent promise equals
sufficient consideration.
The holding in Mills v Wyman,
that moral obligation without a preexisting legal obligation is not sufficient
to support consideration is often considered the traditional rule.
While the holding in Web [inaudible] gallon by contrast is often called the
modern rule.
Can the decision in web be reconciled with mills?
Now perhaps one thing,
the court in Web,
the in the gallon states that the promise or must have received a material
benefit,
uh,
that spurred his promise to repay.
Mr Macallan certainly received a material benefit when his life was saved.
But did Wyman receiving material benefit when mills cared for Wyman son?
Well,
arguably not his son certainly did,
but Wyman's benefit with psychic and it wasn't and his son was already an adult
age and navy.
That's not sufficiently material.
Second,
it's worth noting that,
uh,
why am in himself recanted the promise?
While I'm like the gallon did not McGowan's promise was made in writing and
actually performed until his death.
It wasn't until I after MCGOWAN's death that his executor repudiated the
promise.
In other words,
the court in Web,
the Miguel and may have simply been trying to divide up into state according to
the testators apparent,
uh,
wishes.
As usual,
the restatement has something to say about moral obligation,
which is fairly consistent with the holding in web.
Section 86 of the restatement reads a promise made in recognition of a benefit.
Previously received by the promise or from the primacy is binding to the extent
necessary to prevent injustice and a promise is not binding under the first
subsection.
If the promise he conferred the benefit as a gift or for other reason the
promise or has not been unjustly enriched or to the extent that its value is
disproportionate to the benefit note how the elements of section 86 parallel
those of contracts implied in law that we studied in Bailey versus west,
especially the conferral of a benefit that wasn't confirmed as a gift.
In some ways the modern rule can be seen as allowing recovery,
uh,
when there is moral past consideration when the beneficiary has gone further and
given the court with his or her promises specific price at which to value the
benefit.
It's as if moral consideration is cuase I contract plus an explicit promise.
So would the Mills v Wyman case be decided differently under section 86 of the
restatement?
Well,
maybe not.
First,
the defendant can argue that since the benefit was conferred on an emancipated
son,
there is no need to enforce the promise to prevent injustice.
And second,
the Good Samaritan conferred the benefit as a gift.
There was no intention to charge.
Thus,
the result is arguably the same today as it was in 1825 well,
let's recap a promise given in return for pass.
Good deed creates a moral obligation for the promise,
or today we considered whether it is sufficient consideration to also create a
legal obligation.
If there's a subsequent promise under the traditional rule articulated,
it's not sufficient consideration unless there was some preexisting legal
obligations such as a past due debt that's no longer enforceable.
But under the modern rule,
it is sufficient consideration.
At least when the promises passed,
good deed is created.
A created a material benefit for the promise,
or the restatement is thus consistent with the modern rule.